der wahlabend in münchen bringt die
erkenntnis dass auch die csu ein
wahlverlierer ist weil natürlich die
union im gesamten nach der ära merkel
nun um die macht in berlin wird kämpfen
müssen die csu geht aber die linie die
armin laschet heute abend in berlin
ausgegeben hat er hat ja beansprucht da
ist die union unter der führung der
union eine regierung gebildet wird
obwohl es im vorfeld hier aus münchen
die eine oder andere stimme gab die
besagt hat nein wenn wir auf platz zwei
landen dann sollte doch eventuell die
spd die regierung übernehmen und
versuchen eine regierung zu bilden das
hat sich jetzt geändert an diesem abend
sowohl armin laschet als auch markus
söder haben da eine klare position
gesetzt man muss sehen wie das ganze in
der nacht im laufe der nacht noch
ausgeht wenn vor allem die
briefwahlstimmen ausgezählt sind
jedenfalls diese linie scheint erstmal
zu stehen jedenfalls bis morgen früh bis
die gremien her in der csu-zentrale
tagen und dann mitteilen wie es
weitergehen wird also das ist sozusagen
der kritische teil der andere zeit
plötzlich bezieht sich darauf dass die
csu vorher befürchtet hat nicht über die
fünf prozent hürde zu kommen in bayern
das ist nicht der fall sie legen so am
abend so jetzt bei 33 prozent haben also
die hürde aus eigener kraft geschafft
und die freien wähler das ist auch für
die csu noch wichtig waren es ebenfalls
nicht in den bundestag geschafft ich
hatte am frühen abend die gelegenheit
mit marc busch markus blume den
generalsekretär der csu zu sprechen
vielleicht fangen wir damit an mit dem
was klar ist die csu hat hier in bayern
zwar verloren 5 6 prozent aber den
sprung über die fünf-prozent-hürde
sehr wahrscheinlich geschafft was
überwiegt denn an diesem abend
der ärger über die verluste oder die
freunde des sie es geschafft haben das
ist natürlich eine ambivalente abend
entscheidend war dass wir in eine
position kommen dass wir in deutschland
auch einen regierungsauftrag ableiten
können jedenfalls eine regierungsoption
haben für eine bürgerliche regierung
sind angetreten eine bürgerliche
regierung in diesem land zu bilden und
wir wollten ein linksbündnis verhindern
das ist uns gelungen es gibt die
möglichkeit seine bürgerliche regierung
zu bilden und da werden jetzt unser
augenmerk darauf richten jetzt haben sie
heute abend gesagt das ist doch so in
eine quasi pattsituation geschafft haben
der auch der csu
hätte die csu mit angeschoben durch ihre
kampagne in der letzten jahr 14 tagen
warum haben sie dir nicht vorher schon
richtig dampf gemacht für armin laschet
und gegen allerdings
es ist ja erst in den letzten wochen
auch mit den umfragen deutlich geworden
dass hier konkret ein linksbündnis in
deutschland droht und gleichzeitig ist
erst in den letzten wochen offenbar
geworden dass irgendwie spd und die
grünen ein linksbündnis eben auch nicht
ausgeschlossen haben und das war für uns
der punkt wo wir gesagt haben da müssen
wir dagegenhalten und insofern war das
ein ergebnis eine zuspitzung im
wahlkampf die uns geholfen hat auch dann
noch mal extra viele wählerinnen und
wähler gerade auch in bayern zu
mobilisieren jetzt hat armin laschet in
berlin gesagt und markus söder ebenfalls
also ihr parteichef ja wir wollen jetzt
eine regierung unter der führung der
union bilden was ist denn aber wenn die
spd morgen für vorne legt deswegen haben
wir gesagt wir müssen erstmal das
ergebnis der langen nacht abwarten dass
in vielen wahlkreisen sehr enges rennen
wie dann die endgültige zusammensetzung
des bundestags aussieht und alle
weiteren fragen mit ihnen werden sich
dann morgen die parteigremien
beschäftigen zunächst mal war
entscheidend linksbündnis zu verhindern
und auf der anderen seite
sicherzustellen dass wir in eine
position kommen dass eine bürgerliche
regierung möglich ist unter führung der
union das ist rechnerisch im moment der
fall aber würde man sich dann in so
einer verhandlungssituation nicht sehr
stark erpressbar machen also große
verluste aber trotzdem versuchen mit der
fdp und den grünen ich sage es mal
salopp ins geschäft zu kommen die
aufgabe heißt dann ans land zu denken
das ist die zentrale aufgabe
und alles zu tun das was die menschen
noch erwarten dass ganz offensichtlich
eine regierung auch gebildet die für
stabilität steht die auch für modernität
steht diese ins werk zu setzen das ist
das was wir beitragen möchten und wir
tun das natürlich mit einem ergebnis wo
wir wissen da braucht man eine
ordentliche portion auch in der zukunft
da muss man vielleicht noch mehr
drauflegen aber jetzt werde im moment
etwas was uns viele nicht zugetraut
hätten wenn sie mögen dürfen sie noch
einen satz zu den grünen sagen die
kanzlerkandidatin partei ist angetreten
ins kanzleramt einziehen zu wollen
landet bei 14,6 prozent ist immer noch
dass sie zugelegt haben aber das
kanzleramt ist weit weg ist das thema
jetzt endgültig durch man muss die
grünen als partei immer ernst nehmen wir
haben das getan wir werden es auch in
zukunft tun
aber am ende war richtig dass wir auch
unseren wahlkampf sehr stark
konzentriert haben auf die
auseinandersetzung mit olaf scholz mit
der spd zum schluss die hf de zeigt
deutlich nach unten glauben sie dass die
rechtspopulisten jetzt inszeniert
überschritten haben das bekämpfen der
afg bleibt eine daueraufgabe
man muss klare stoppschilder aufstellen
um viele bürgerinnen bürger in
deutschland haben gemerkt dass diese
partei paktiert mit querdenkern an
manchen stellen sogar mit extremisten
und ich glaube es ist einfach nicht
angebracht dass eine solche partei dann
quasi als verlängerter arm von solchen
bewegungen im parlament sitzt viele
bürger haben das realisieren und das
zeigt eben auch dass die auf dem rückzug
ist tages bruno vielen dank für das
gespräch dagegen